okay now there's no division symbol on
your keyboard not on a regular QWERTY
keyboard anyway so that's why they use
this backslash just watch out there's
two slashes on your keyboard of the
forward slash goes like that and this is
the back slash so make sure you select
that one okay so when I hit enter
nothing happens why didn't anything
happen like no calculation to a place
why was that because I didn't yeah very
good there's no formula that's actually
happened I haven't said equals so this
is just a label okay but now I am going
to do a formula so if I want each of
these in the second column to be a
fraction like if I want to get 1/2 1/3
1/4 of fifth sixth out of these what
formulas should I put in yeah I'm going
to go 1 divided by whatever the
left-hand cell was right so I'm going to
again I'm just going to click on that
cell or touch it ok so when you're here
you like wow this is the wonder of a
spreadsheet that I've used to see ok but
that was obviously not the point go back
to that cell copy it and then paste it
for as far as you'd like
if I did I go down
there we go that'll do
okay so hopefully you've got forgive it
looks somewhat like this now are you
with me hands up who's looks like this
okay fantastic thank you very much now
let's start searching and looking and
wondering okay now computers have limits
right so you can see for instance we
know that that decimal place is not
supposed to be a seven over there what
should that disappear it's a six but of
course it's giving us a 7 because
surrounding on so computers or computers
have limited memory space so eventually
at some point they decide okay forget it
I'm not going to do this forever I'm
just going to stop at some point and
just give you whatever is closest which
is the rounding okay but we know this
actually indicates something that goes
on forever have a look which numbers
have terminating decimals and which ones
have recurring decimals if you notice by
the way I've got my two my two top
things my labels here they're not moving
even though I'm scrolling down what I've
done is I've frozen that top row
depending on the what you're using for
your spreadsheets freezing rows or
columns is in a slightly different spot
so I'm not going to worry about getting
you all to do that but if you want to do
that later on just call me over and I'll
show you how to find it so you've got
you've got numbers here and they
terminate right and then you've got
these other ones and they seem to recur
over and over and over right which are
the ones that terminate and which are
the ones that recur hmm have a look how
did you guys get did anyone to go
certainly I think I'm like 50-something
here we go further than that at a
certain point it looks like they seem to
all start recurring except every now and
then every now and then you hit one that
terminates okay so the reason we created
this spreadsheet is just to take some of
the legwork out but now it's time to
pick up your pen and do some thinking
about this right clearly it seems like
terminating decimals are less common
than recurring decimals return decimals
seem to happen
all over the place especially when you
get to bigger numbers terminating
decimals hardly ever so let's make it a
little column of terminating decimals
okay
what kinds of decimals terminate and
there's um there's few enough that we
can literally miss them out so we've got
one alright fine
that's not particularly interesting
whatever okay then you've got on this
page at least I've got quite a few right
can you call them out for me
one other ones you've got I'm going to
write them as fractions you'll see why
in a second so 0.5 of course is a heart
what's the next one good yep
and on this page n/a okay if I go a
little bit further you can do this
yourself on this next page I only have
two
I had I had five on the previous page
but this time I've only got what's that
first one one over ten and okay then you
go a little bit further yeah I go well
they're saying to spread out a little
bit what do you see here one of two one
over twenty one over 25 there's one
there look at that one what's that can I
stop doing the scrolling can you tell me
the next one's giving you quite a spread
sheet what's the next one one over is it
forty here it's one what's next what are
you sure are you sure
I think the next one fifty if you look
in you think you've got one that
terminates I want you to look at it a
little more carefully mine don't seem to
do anything in terms of like they do
stop they do stop but that's because
there's a limitation of the computer
depending on what spreadsheet you've got
you can actually change the number of
decimal places it'll do to a certain
minute okay and I think one of the few
T's the last one I've got after that
they just keep on becoming you know
repetitious so now yeah
64 is your next one isn't it which I
didn't go up to you okay so pause there
for a moment this is enough for us to
think where's my bottom because I need
more space to write okay what the
Dickens is going on this seems like a
really huge apt mess of our fractions
what is the pattern one thing that we
have observes is they seem to be getting
less and less frequent right you have to
go I think the next one is one of the
A's and it whatever 80 I am predicting
that the next one would be or B 1 over
100 okay so when you have a look at the
gaps between them these gaps are getting
larger and larger and larger right have
a look do you see any commonalities
between in this list of numbers is there
anything that stands out to you this is
a real question
well you recognize none of them are
multiples of 3 that's weird isn't it
no multiples of 3 there are some
multiples there is an interesting line
to go down what kinds of multiples do
you see that stand out see if we're
saying again 2 & 2 & 5
hold on a second 2 & 5 let's figure out
them one at a time
multiples of two multiples of two you've
got multiples of two whoops you
Valter do you write you've got two and
then four but you do not have six then
you have eight you do have ten but you
don't have twelve or fourteen you go
straight to sixteen so these are not
just multiples of two have a look
2 4 8 16 32 64 these are not multiples
of 2 or even though they are in fact
more specifically those are the mental
powers of two okay there will be one
over 128 will be on this listener to
your calculator what's 1 over 128 can
you tell me what it is I know what that
is but what is it is a decimal that
doesn't terminate doesn't terminate ok
and it stops it stops